tensions still very high between the
u.s. and North Korea and earlier today
as I said North Korea announced that
they will have the capability of firing
ballistic missiles at the u.s. territory
of Guam by the end of the month it's
just amazing
well I couldn't believe this but
apparently it prompted the Guam tourist
board to respond with this ad there's
never been a better time to visit Guam
you'll have it all to yourself right now
we're offering first-class one-way
flights to Guam for only $5 you'll have
the whole floor of any 5-star luxury
hotel free minibar free regular bar just
hop over and help yourself use a
different toilet to prepay t-shirt fish
snorkel scuba just pick up the abandoned
gear and go strangle a pelican if you
want we don't care and if you stick
around to the end of the month you'll
have front row seats to one of the
biggest fireworks displays the world has
ever seen
whoa your guala love it enjoy the
gwamorous night boys bring your guava in
Guam ah there's log wall to your Guam
pewter and Guam on down to Guam there's
no Guam like the present okay that's not
a pun who cares three two
Bureau shouldn't do that
[Applause]
you